>> THE CITY OF NORTH DAKOTA
WAS REALLY HAPPY WHEN POTENTIAL
FOR A NEW CORNELL CAME TO TOWN.
WELL THAT WAS UNTIL THE CITIZENS
THEY ARE LEARNED ABOUT WHO THE
COMPANY WAS ASSOCIATED.
>> THEY TOLD US THE AIR FORCE
OFFICIALS HAD RAISED NO CONTENT,
THEY TOLD US THAT, THEY HAVE
PROPERLY DECIDED THE
CORPORATION, AND THEY SEE NO
PROBLEM WITH IT.
WHICH JUST SIMPLY ISN'T TRUE.
THEY DID A GOOGLE SEARCH, THAT
WAS THE VETTING PROCESS.
IF THE COMPANY.
>> WILL BACK IN JULY, "THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE" FIRST BRANCH OF
THE STORY OF A CHINESE COMPANY
AS YOU JUST HEARD NAME FOOL
THING, IT IS ATTEMPTING TO BUILD
A CORNELL JUST MILES FROM
AMERICAN AIR FORCE SPACE, WHICH
IS YESTERDAY THE COMMITTEE ON
FOREIGN INVESTIGATION IN THE
UNITED STATES CONCLUDED THAT ITS
REVIEW SAYING THAT THEY DO NOT
HAVE JUST DICTION TO BLOCK THIS.
WILL END UP THE VERY BLUNTLY,
THE COMMITTEE THAT CONGRESSMEN
DATA, AND GAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
PROTECT AMERICA'S NATIONAL
SECURITY, IS ALLOWING A CHINESE
BUSINESS, WITH TIES TO BEIJING
AND MEANS THE CCP, TO OPERATE
NEAR MILES FROM AN AMERICAN
MILITARY INSTALLATION.
WHAT IS GENERAL AUSTIN?
MILLIE?
WHAT SPENDING SO MUCH MONEY ON
NATIONAL DEFENSE, WHEN OBVIOUSLY
BUDDY IN WASHINGTON TENDS TO
DEFEND THIS COUNTRY HERE ON OUR
LAND AT ALL.
HE NOW IS GORDON CHANG, A SENIOR
FELLOW WHO HAS BEEN CHECKING
CHINA'S LAND PURCHASES HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES FOR YEARS.
GORDON, WHY ARE WE GOING TO
ALLOW CHINA, TO FLY UP KEY
AGRICULTURAL TRACKS IN THE
UNITED STATES LET ALONE, LANDS
NEAR AN AIR FORCE BASE I THINK
PEOPLE ARE JUST SCRATCHING THEIR
HEADS TONIGHT.
>> WILL THEY HAVE TO, YOU
CAN'T REMEMBER THAT THIS COMPANY
IS CHINESE.
AND THAT MEANS IN THE
COMMUNIST PARTY'S TOP-DOWN
SYSTEM, IT DID NOT REFUSE A TO
SPY.
ALSO, THE CHINESE 2017 NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE LAW ARTICLE SEVEN
AND 14 WILL REQUIRE EVERY
CHINESE COMPANY TO SPY, IF THEY
RECEIVE A DEMAND TO DO SO.
SO, THIS IS A COMPANY ALL THEIR
COMPULSION COMMIT ESPIONAGE.
THIS IS LET PEACE OF MIND WITHIN
12 MILES OF GRAND FORKS
AIR FORCE BASE.
IF GET SENSITIVE SATELLITES
THERE, THIS IS THE VERY NATURE
THAT IS DANGER TO AMERICAN
SECURITY.
AND WHETHER YOU GOOGLE OR NOT,
THEREFORE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
THIS.
>> NOW THE MAYOR OF
GRAND FORKS SAID A INTERESTING
REACTION GOING INTO THE NEWS
YESTERDAY WATCH THIS.
>> INITIAL SURPRISE BECAUSE AT
45 MORE DAYS WE EXPECTED FOR
THEM TO TAKE THE FULL AMOUNT OF
TIME.
SO THEY HAD A 45 EXTENSION SO
THEY COULD HAVE ASKED FOR MORE
INFORMATION FROM THE TWO PARTIES
INVOLVED.
>> GORDON, DIDN'T TAKE THE
EXTENSION THAT THEY COULD HAVE
USED TO THOROUGHLY LOOK AT THIS,
IF IT'S RUSH THROUGH.
IF SOMEONE JUST TRYING TO
PLACATE, PLEASE, BEND OVER BACK
THIS FOR THE CTP IN THE
UNITED STATES AT THIS POINT?
IS THAT WHAT WE CAN CONCLUDE?
>> THAT IS AN EXPIRATION CAN
COME UP WITH.
AND BY THE WAY, EVEN IF THE
COMMITTEE ON FOREIGN
INVESTIGATION IN U.S. DIDN'T
HAVE JURISDICTION, THE PRESIDENT
OF UNITED STATES USING HIS
POWERS UNDER THE INTERNATIONAL
EMERGENCY ECONOMIC POWERS ARE AS
OF 1977, TO PREVENT THIS LAND
PURCHASE.
SO, THERE'S A LIQUOR CAN BE
DONE, WE STILL NEED TO KEEP THE
PRESSURE UP BUT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
WE HAVE A WHITE HOUSE, WE HAVE A
PENTAGON THAT SEEMS TO TURN THE
NOT TO DEFEND THE UNITED STATES.
>> WILL GORDON, HOW MANY
AMERICAN COMPANIES ARE BEING
ALLOWED TO BUY TRACTS OF LAND IN
CHINA?
NEAR CHINESE OR ANYWHERE, NEAR
CHINESE MILITARY INSTALLATION
THEY HAVE A LIST OF THOSE?
THEY WANT ZERO.
ZERO LAUREL, THIS IS JUST AGAIN
AN ISSUE OF RECIPROCITY, AND
THIS IS NOT THE ONLY CASE THAT
WE HAVE.
WE HAVE FORMER CHINESE OFFICERS,
ACTUALLY BOUGHT A LOT OF ACREAGE
NEAR AN AIR FORCE BASE IN
SOUTHERN TEXAS.
AND THERE'S ANOTHER CASE OF THIS
IS WELL.
SO THIS IS SEEN TO BE
SYMPTOMATIC, AND THESE ARE THE
COMMUNIST PARTY IS USING THESE
PURCHASES TO SPY ON THE U.S.
I MEAN HOW DUMB CAN WE BE?
>> AND ALMOST YESTERDAY ALMOST
200 CHINESE COMPANIES AVOIDED
BEING DELISTED FROM THE U.S.
STOCK EXCHANGE AFTER OUR
ACCOUNTING WATCHDOG BOARD,
CLAIMED THAT THEY HAD FULL
ACCESS AND AUDIT EXPECTIONS
LATER ON.
HERE'S THE CHAIR OF THAT BOY
BOARD DEFENDING THIS DECISION.
HE ONCE INVESTED ARE BETTER
PROTECTED TODAY BECAUSE THE PCU
WAS ABLE TO SEND IN OUR
INSPECTORS AND INVESTIGATORS AND
REALLY LOOK AT THE BOOKS OF THE
AUDIT FIRMS IN CHINA.
AND FIND OUT WHETHER THERE'S
PROBLEMS, AND NOW WERE ABLE TO
HOLD THOSE FIRMS ACCOUNTABLE TO
FIX THOSE PROBLEMS.
>> GORDON?
IS THERE ANY INDICATION THAT DUE
DILIGENCE IS EVEN POSSIBLE WHEN
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THE CCP IN
THEIR TACTICS AND THEIR
STRATEGIES AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES?
>> KNOW.
AND WHAT'S EVEN WORSE, IS THAT
WE SEND OUR HOT AUDITORS TO
HONG KONG WHERE WE REVIEWED
THOSE BOOKS.
WE DIDN'T SEND THEM INTO THE
MAIN THEN, WE DIDN'T SEND INTO
THE COMPANIES THEMSELVES.
SO I DID NOT SEE HOW WE CAN SAY
REGARD TO DILIGENCE WHERE WE CAN
HOLD THEM TO ACCOUNT, THIS WAS
JUST FUNDAMENTALLY WRONG IN
TERMS OF THE AGREE